drew barrymore look at her she's here
live and in colorado hi guys show her hi
drew she's bright she's bubbly she's a
host of what's your name of your show
it's called the drewberry show which is
so weird i don't know why they called it
that
it works for you it airs of course as
you know right here on cbs but in a
powerful interview that she had with
machine gun kelly she opens up about her
own mental health struggles the rapper
and the actor was talking about how he
sometimes feels pressure to hide his
feelings so he joined drew to promote
his new unisex nail polish line that he
has while giving her a manicure he did
he did it looks so good his product is
fantastic
so wait let me get let me do this yeah
it didn't didn't end there so he gave
her he was giving her manicure but then
they had an honest conversation about
not feeling okay and then seeking help
i think i'm
new to being vulnerable outside of songs
so it's like like i see a lot of
pictures of me
and there's like smiles on them and i'm
always like it's just weird though
because i didn't feel good at all that
day and i
i kind of
am
sick of smiling on days when i don't
feel like smiling and i feel like this
odd pressure because i don't want
um like my fans to
think that i'm taking something for
granted so if like i accept an award and
i'm like super smiley but behind the
scenes i was really
there was like stuff going on or i
didn't feel i don't know like a lot of
what i do is for other people and i
haven't given myself the
the time to just
accept that it's okay to not be okay so
i i didn't just my whole point is i just
didn't want to bring that into the show
i'd love to talk about funny stuff and
anything that you have for me i would
love to just like
i would love to just get out of what i'm
what i'm doing and like
i don't mean to sound creepy but i like
you so much more
i really do in fact we were just talking
about where different people were from
and someone was like why do you know
utah and i was like i went there to go
change my life and
i just you know i went through a really
painful divorce and i wasn't doing very
well and i just wanted to go talk to
some people and how to
pull myself out of a hole and i had
these two kids that i had to fight for
and
i needed help
and drew barrymore joins us now in
studio wow is right so he came out and
he immediately started talking about how
he was feeling and then you opened up to
him he sat down he said i want to admit
something i'm not okay right now
and
i'm not a rug sweeper so i tried to make
it as comfortable and welcoming but it
takes two to tango and what i mean by
that is
we were just set to do an interview
about his nail polish undone yeah and
you do you know him did you guys know
each other i'm just a really big fan so
i'd been chasing him to do an interview
and he doesn't do a lot of press
so i don't know what it was that he felt
safe
but he broke ice he broke
a sort of pattern and he admitted that
he doesn't feel good sometimes he
doesn't want to have to smile through it
he wants to go on a new journey
of bringing people into that
with nervousness and tentative you can
tell this is like putting on ice skates
and learning to navigate and i just was
so surprised
by his vulnerability as was he and then
we make jokes about his publicist
flipping out up but then you started
talking about your divorce and you
haven't talked about your divorce in
this way but and also what's so special
about your show and i think about you as
an interviewer is he comes and says this
unexpected thing that's that's difficult
and rather than make a joke and move on
to a happier subject you actually sat
with it and then offered up your own
admission thank you for seeing it that
way i think we are in a new guard moment
i had just recently that weekend been
with my girlfriend whose daughter said
i'm struggling i want to be like these
instagram girls and maybe i should alter
myself to be that i get home that night
and i see bella hadid crying saying i
can't keep this up
this is hard for me too
i think it is time for us especially
coming out of what we've come out of
is how can we
show our vulnerability
how can we talk about if something is
going on
what is the path to getting better and
then
talking about that journey and being
more communicative i wouldn't be
surprised if there is a revolt against
the perfection
right now that we are all forced to see
and feel through social media
instagram is having a soul search of its
own how do they approach teenage girls
we're in an impasse and a crux of a
moment
where i think talking about how we
figure ourselves out how we fix
ourselves
takes a journey solutions and most
people do it in private and i've been
very private about a lot of my struggles
what did you share drew about this um i
shared you know this i'm gonna say
something for the first time uh in a
long time i have not had a drink of
alcohol in two and a half years
and it was something that i realized
just did not serve me in my life and
when you are
stuck in a pattern
or if you are going through things and
you not only admit them out loud but you
force yourself to say
i'm willing to make big changes i think
we all think we're very weak when we
don't make those changes that inner
dialogue proves to us you're not capable
of change you are weak you're staying
stuck and when you break that cycle the
empowerment that comes out of it that
says i'm not weak i'm actually strong
i've proven to myself that i am capable
of change and i believe people are
capable of big changes drew what is the
biggest difference between the drew that
would casually drink
in the drew that is practicing sobriety
and
it's it's finally you know i love this
quote insecurity is loud confidence is
quiet
this was something i didn't talk to
people about for years because it was
this quiet confident journey
of just going
i just want to figure this out
and go about this with no profession no
public
anything let me do this quietly and
privately and now it's been long enough
where i'm in a lifestyle that i know is
really working on a high road for
my little journey
and there's so much peace finally being
had where there were demons and how do
we
slay those dragons and get there's the
best quote ever too trust patterns not
apologies not only does that apply to
your outlook on others it should be
turned back on yourself yes so how do we
break cycles
and can we get to conversations that are
funny
and full of insights but take back the
layers so we can get to the humanity
of what we're all going through and help
each other through it i find
authenticity always works but i'm
curious after you've shared something
that's so personal did you uh feel
relief or did you feel regret that you
didn't go oh my god whatever really
admitting it now for the first time um
so i talked about going to utah with
machine gun kelly because he was
you know when he sat down and said i'm
not doing okay
i
we had a very different show planned
with him and i just pivoted and went
you're in the right place
let's break this down and i think also
what he's doing and i know for myself
what i'm doing we're not doing this for
public attention
it's almost like i breathe a sigh of
relief by telling my truth
and i would like to move forward in a
more honest
fashion that is more conducive to my
mental piece can can you stay through
the breakthrough yeah i know we were in
here but can you just stay sure
absolutely because we want to continue
okay great thank you
welcome back to cbs mornings we wanted
to spend some more time talking to drew
barrymore who's been very honest about
some mental health challenges she's had
came up during a conversation she had on
her own show with rapper machine gun
kelly and we'll see that interview
tomorrow yes you know before the show
started this season you had told us that
you were hoping to go deeper yes that
you wanted to explore really personal
conversations i did did you think that
would involve you
one of the things we did in the premiere
episode was that uh going around the way
that i grew up in los angeles being in
an institution being blacklisted you
know
having him you know everything sort of
taken away so young and having to
rebuild so i think i'm very
not into the sensationalism because at
13 when my life was exposed ever since
then i've really thought about
how do we not tmi
while remaining so honest and open
and one thing that i do feel a little
liberated about and machine gun kelly is
saying i struggle when i don't want to
smile but i'm in front of cameras or i'm
on social media or i'm winning an award
and that isn't where i'm at can i be
honest about where i'm at can i bring a
different truth
to this
um
i think when i've tried to talk to
people about a divorce or going through
difficult things maybe people think like
i figured out so many problems when i
was young because it was so hard then
we continue
to confront things
with each decade of our life that almost
surpasses what we thought we had seen
and i'm interested in that conversation
that we don't fix it move on and it
never breaks again
we are on that roller coaster and the
revelation of being in my mid to late
40s now and realizing that there is one
thing we have control over and it is our
behavior
our reaction our patterns the cycles we
need to break the way we treat people
and how we process all of it and what we
put out there and now working from that
space
that's changed so much for me so let's
talk about patterns when it comes to
love
preparing to talk to you today i saw
that about a year ago at this time
talking about relationships you said you
were as afraid to fall in love again
as you would be to not find love again
yeah explain that do you still feel that
way well i think you know when you think
it may never happen again who is
inspired by that i'm an absolute
romantic
but i'm also a real pragmatist and what
i have learned
is
so
empowering to know that i could spot
something now very quickly whereas i
think a lot of us go through a very long
period before we can really discover our
strengths and truth and what we're
willing to accept
and how our behavior affects others i
don't care in any relationship it just
wasn't all one person's fault
it's probably what is your part in it
what is it that is a trigger for you
what is it you can conduct yourself
differently in the future how can you
choose differently all of that kind of
like maturity and growing up is not bad
it's kind of not overrated it's really
exciting to go through this day of life
smarter than the last because you can
live a better fuller life
and if you have fears
why are those fears there
what are they actually about don't be
crumbled by them be pragmatic in your
approach of
this is what i'm not looking for this is
maybe what i am open to speaking i i do
think as a final note on machine gun
kelly i i think it matters that a man is
coming forward and saying i'm not okay
because
it's not always been the case that men
feel comfortable doing so and for a guy
like him to do it i think it's a good
example and he has this wonderful love
with this wonderful woman and she says
this thing
that i will leave all romantics with
okay leave it which is when he said when
he really met her and was falling for
her he said i feel lost and she looked
to him and said then let's find you oh
all right megan so i like it good all
right that's tomorrow thank you so much
for coming and thank you so much for
staying thank you we will continue the
love conversation
we'll continue that love conversation
can you always gail your favorite topic
and you're coming on to do oprah's
favorite things also on the show yes yes
which i'm very excited yes you can watch
more of her interview with machine gun
kelly on the drew barrymore show that's
tomorrow you can visit the
drewberrymarshow.com to find out when
and where to see it in your city